- [Interviewer] All right.
Latia?
- [Latia] Yes.
- [Interviewer] Latia where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Latia] Watts, California.
- [Interviewer] And, tell
me about your family.
You grew up with both of your parents?
- [Latia] No.
- [Interviewer] Who raised you?
- Basically the streets,
but my mother was 15 when she had me.
My father, I've only met
him three times in my life.
- [Interviewer] You only
met your dad three times?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Where was he?
- In and out of prison for murder.
- [Interviewer] Murder?
- He murdered quite a bit of people.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
- Difficult, very difficult.
- [Interviewer] What were
some of the hard parts?
- Dealing with men.
Dealing with men,
alcohol
and drugs.
- [Interviewer] Was there
any abuse from anyone
when you were a kid?
- I just, abuse came
from beat the meat mems.
- [Interviewer] From who?
- Beat the meat mems.
- [Interviewer] Who's that?
- Men that you would walk past
when you going to school as a girl.
They would call you to the car.
When you go to the car,
you'd think they wanna ask you questions
they had no pants on,
they would be playing with their penis.
- [Interviewer] Oh jeez.
- I was 12 when I first seen it.
- [Interviewer] This was on
your way to school every day?
- Every day.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- I was a little fat girl
who went to school every day.
Some days I was scared,
some days I wasn't.
I learned not to be scared anymore
cause I knew it was
gonna happen every day.
- [Interviewer] And then what,
what age were you when you left home?
- 12 and a half.
- [Interviewer] You left home at 12?
- [Interviewer] 12 and a half.
Where'd you go?
- Just the streets.
I kind of bounced from place to place.
I was more, I got involved with older men.
A lot of older men.
I call them cat daddies.
(interviewer chuckles)
- [Interviewer] What did
these older men do for you?
- Gave me shelter and food.
Almost like a pimp but wasn't a pimp.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- They gave me drugs and my alcohol.
- [Interviewer] What
was your drug back then?
- My drug back then was heroin.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- As a girl yeah.
- [Interviewer] At 12 years old?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- I learned down.
- [Interviewer] That's really.
- It's called numbing yourself.
I numbed myself for years.
I still numb myself to this day.
- [Interviewer] And then,
so your teenage years,
you finished high school or no?
- Yeah I managed to finish high school.
After I finished high school
I was raped by a crack
head, and I had a son.
- [Interviewer] You had a son.
Okay. Did you raise your son?
- Off and on.
- [Interviewer] Who helped you?
- A little bit of everybody.
- [Interviewer] Do you
still talk to your son?
- Off and on.
Not too often. He safe.
- [Interviewer] That's good.
- I chose a better life for
him than I have for myself.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Good for him.
And then where did your
life go in your twenties?
- Spiral down hill.
That's when I started popping pills.
Pills and alcohol was my choice.
- [Interviewer] Was that
your- that's your go to now?
- Yeah that was my go to.
Tylenol 5,
Vicodin,
any narc I can get hold of.
I pop 30 to 50 pills a day.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- With alcohol.
- [Interviewer] And they
sell those here on skid row?
- They didn't sell them on skid row.
I conned them outta somebody.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see.
I was a con artist during that time.
- [Interviewer] Oh I understand.
- I needed what I needed
during that time to survive.
Other than that I get the shakes real bad.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yeah you shake.
Alcoholics shake, I shake.
Pills, pills kinda help
it along a little bit.
- [Interviewer] Right.
It might help you sleep
for a minute but not long.
You wake up to the same name
nightmare over and over again.
Everyday.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- Every day of my life.
Down here on Skid Row, you see everything.
You see nudity, you see rape,
you see murder, you see it all.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
What have you done for
money over the years?
- I've sold drugs.
I've sold myself.
Sold myself to my cat daddies.
Some of my cat daddies was my dope man.
That was the best of man.
They're older men more gentle,
more gentle.
A lot of times just conversation.
- [Interviewer] All right.
- And a lot of times sex.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- But I got what I wanted to fix my habit.
And my habit was more
important than anything
during that time.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- But through it all I made sure that
the child I had was safe.
Always.
- [Interviewer] How is he today?
- He's growing.
- [Interviewer] He's good?
- He's a young man.
- [Interviewer] Good.
- [Interviewer] And what are you?
Are you still drinking and popping pills-
- I drink everyday.
- [Interviewer] And pills too?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Where do you find it?
Where do you buy pills?
- You buy the pills from
anybody, they have tents outside.
So you just go to to
the tent that you want.
- [Interviewer] You figure it out.
It's all available here.
- Everything you want
from drugs to alcohol,
anything you want.
That's the 24 hour drug
store, and a pharmacy.
- [Interviewer] (laughs)
You can get pretty much
anything you want down here.
If you know what to say.
- A 24 hour performance and drug store.
You can have it all.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- You don't have to go without.
- [Interviewer] How many years?
How many years have you been on skid row?
- Four.
- [Interviewer] Only four?
- Yeah, last year I was raped on skid row.
I thought I could trust the
old cat daddy daughter time
but I couldn't.
I jumped out of his truck and I cut him.
With a butcher knife about this long.
And I ran for my life.
I ran, I just ran, kept running.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most dangerous thing
you've run across?
- [Latia] Watched somebody
get killed. Stabbed.
Buying drugs.
Women get raped for no reason.
They just snatch women
off the streets now.
Trafficking, I've seen trafficking.
You're not careful, you end
up the one of them trucks
and you're a goner.
So you had to learn how to
be street smart as well.
His body, his drug addiction, alcoholism.
I learned to grow.
Coming up I was a big girl.
Nobody knew who I was,
and nobody really knows who I am anymore.
I was real big, not anymore.
I'm a little thing.
I grew up, everybody called me good girl.
I was a good girl going bad.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Latia] Very bad.
I did what I had to do to survive.
And I still do what I
have to do survive now.
- [Interviewer] How old are you now?
- [Latia] I'm in my 50s.
- [Interviewer] You're in your 50s?
Do you- is your mom still around?
- [Latia] No. She's
been gone for 29 years.
- [Interviewer] Oh, wow, sorry.
How about your, how about your dad?
- [Latia] He's in prison.
- [Interviewer] He's still in prison?
- [Latia] Yeah, he's in (inaudible).
He murdered a lot of people, coming up.
I only think I know some of them now.
On the streets, if you ever need anything,
Daddy would take care of it.
I walked away from him.
- [Interviewer] Do you
know anything about him?
Oh, too much about him.
I come from a long line of criminals
and criminals in my background.
A lot of my uncles was criminals.
My auntie, she's the only
person who drove her Rose
to the- she's the queen queen,
the queen queen of dope.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
The queen of dope.
- [Interviewer] Now
you'd mentioned outside
that your dad was a pedophile.
- Yeah, a pedophile and
he's a serial killer.
He killed a lot of people.
The last time I seen him
he was shackled like
Kunta Kinte from Roots.
He had a cop to his neck,
a cop to his waist, a cop to both arms.
One here, one there,
all together six cops.
Six (inaudible), and
six high profile guns.
(inaudible) murder his brother in prison.
They hung him from the jail cell.
- [Interviewer] They hung who?
- They hung my father's
brother from a jail cell.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see.
- They had no police.
All the guys blocked the
streets for Cadillacs.
They refused to have the cops in here
because the cops murdered his brother.
That's the last time I seen him.
I was young.
- [Interviewer] And then you
also mentioned your dad was a-
- He's weird, I call it weird.
- [Interviewer] You were saying
your dad was a serial killer
- He was, he killed his
best friend's, best friend
(inaudible)
Him and his best friend
were as close at two things.
He knocked on his best
friend "What do I do first?"
After he found his best friend
was sleeping with his mom.
His best friend.
Mom was used to him coming to
the front door all the time.
So she didn't say nothing about it.
So soon as best friend came
to the door, he blew his face
off.
- [Interviewer] Oh jeez.
- He went to jail for
five years and got out.
He came out again after five years.
A woman said she was pregnant,
he said she was lying.
He beat her to death with a
bumper jack and a tire iron.
Back in jail for five more years.
Got back out, says she
was raped on the street.
He walked up to the dude
didn't say nothing to him,
blew his head off.
Back in jail again.
He just kept murdering people.
The slightest little thing
they say triggered him.
They call him wild. He's a wild man.
- [Interviewer] Looking back at your life,
and the parents that you were dealt and
the environment that you grew up in,
do you do you ever have regrets
that this is the world
that you grew up in?
- Yes, every day of my life.
Some days I want to commit suicide.
Some days I don't want to live.
Some days I wish I wasn't here anymore.
I've tried to OD on
pills before, on alcohol.
I got my stomach pumped plenty a times.
I guess it just, I guess
I didn't do it right.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I mean, did you ever have hope that
a better life might happen for you?
- I dream of it, I dream
of a lot of things.
But I don't have it, I'm still out here.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it's a
rough way to grow up, right?
- Yes it is.
- [Interviewer] There's no
hope, there's no opportunity.
There's no-
- No, now to this day I want to give up.
Everyday I want to give up.
I don't know what keeps me going.
I wake up in the morning,
I got to have my drink.
I gotta have my alcohol.
- [Interviewer] And the alcohol
numbs you from the pain?
- It numbs me from the
pain everyday of my life.
I call it makes me boilermakers.
Hello my boilermakers.
- [Interviewer] What's a boiler maker?
I know I've, I've heard
of them, but what is it?
- That's beer and hard
liquor they mixed together.
You mix them together.
- [Interviewer] And you do
that how early in the morning?
- As early as I can get up and get it.
- [Interviewer] First
thing in the morning?
- Yeah. That's my coffee.
- [Interviewer] (laughs)
That's your coffee.
- That's my coffee in the morning.
Some days I eat, some days I don't eat.
A lot of days I don't eat.
If it comes to me eaten
or getting my alcohol,
I'm gonna take my alcohol over food.
I don't need no food to do my drink.
Some days I wake up,
I don't remember what even
happened to me anymore.
A lot of times I woke
up, one time I woke up
no clothes on, I don't know
what happened to me at all.
Do this day I don't know
what happened to me.
- [Interviewer] Right.
And what do you do for money today?
It's the same thing you've always done?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Okay.
You don't need to get into details.
Well, Latia thank you,
thank you so much for
telling me your story.
- [Latia] Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Good luck with everything.
- [Interviewer] Your attitude is great,
despite all the hell you've been through.
- [Latia] Thank you
very much, you as well.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.